welcome to pi data global 21 2021.
i'm happy to have
uh i'm sorry if i mispronounce your name
vinnie jazwell with us and uh
since this is your time i'll hand it off
to you
awesome uh thank you uh hello everyone
uh thanks for making time to attend my
session today um in this uh talk uh we
will learn about how to do data
engineering for a successful machine
learning
project um i have worked with a lot of
customers in the digital native unicorn
fortune 500 companies so whatever i'm
going to talk today it's a combined uh
wealth of knowledge from all those
experiences
i am vinnie jaswal a developer advocate
at databricks where i help data
practitioners to be successful
building on data bricks and open source
technologies because i can highly
embrace uh open source technologies as
well as help developers in um being a
part of the community so i um i work on
apache spark delta ml flow and other
technologies
so
uh let me tell you a little bit about my
career journey so um i started off with
undergrad in electronics and
communication engineering from india
moreover i chose this field because i
was fascinated by the digital
communication between satellites uh
evolution of uh smart cellular phones
from like heavy electronics to a very
lighter cell phones and
robotics use cases were evolving and it
was becoming more realistic
and then to pursue higher education uh
because i was so um
i was so fascinated and i loved digital
communications i wanted to pursue my
masters
from ut dallas
in telecommunication but soon after when
i saw the booming age of data i started
my master's in information technology
and management from ut dallas um to
further gain industrial experience i
worked at an audit firm as a data
engineering intern and soon after i did
a second internship at southwest
airlines as a maintenance quality uh
data analyst um over there i had fun and
fascinating experience because i got to
work on the data of maintenance of the
flights and providing intelligence
around improving the quality of fleets
so that was pretty cool
and then um i
moved to uh workforce city i had a
variety of experiences at city worked
there for like over
five years and i started working on the
infrastructure side when i joined uh
that's where i passed where i was
started with managing applications which
would go on thousands or
uh 400k uh city machines and then
i worked on a project which allowed me
to gain experience from moving um
on-prem to cloud um and that was a huge
success
then i transitioned on to working
on data science and i was instrumental
in building data science platform at
city
um
over there i
kind of felt like my experience was
getting limited to just the um the city
and banking industry so i wanted to like
uh explore a lot of
other use cases and wanted to help out
what other ai use cases i can uh explore
so i started working at databricks where
i have worked on at least
100 plus data and ai architectures and
projects for our customers in the
you know different spaces and different
verticals
um now i'm doing developer advocacy for
data and ai practitioners
globally uh so
that's pretty exciting uh you will also
find me uh
doing a tech talk or maybe
working with developers uh for delta
like oss
and i'm also co-authoring a book on
judge like the definitive guide so that
was a little bit about me
um
now
since we are here and we are gonna talk
about data science and ai uh i want to
give you the first sense of why
i'm so excited about this and why i
think it's a huge opportunity for uh
companies so as we know data and ai has
massive potential with the growing uh
data in terms of volume variety and
velocity
organizations are now combining massive
data processing with machine learning
and business intelligence capabilities
to unlock business value
so let's take a look at
how the data landscape is evolving and
how the organization are
future proofing the architecture to
become completely data driven and
successful uh
with their ai projects
let's first start with what data teams
want
um being in the data space for many
years myself i regularly talk uh to the
subject matter experts in this space um
you know this is what we want
um this is what the data teams care
about so before diving into technology
um
let me give primers on three main uh
three main ask from data teams they
really want the productivity for their
teams
meaning that if uh they have an ai
project and they want to spend uh as
much time on getting the value from the
business
uh from generating for generating the
business insights rather than working
mainly on the infrastructure side and
pulling all the resources into
infrastructure sites so they want to
accelerate that uh
project
the project work um second what are the
capabilities that we can drive
or we can get to drive new use cases
to power our business that's uh that's
one of the things they ask for and then
they really want to understand how they
can drive efficiencies because they have
amazing talent and they want to make
sure that their ai applications are
successful and if uh their teams are
working efficiently
uh and some of this things i'm seeing is
around simplicity practitioners may be
like i don't want to focus on things
that aren't my core competitive
advantage so those sort of things
um
so i talked a little bit about how data
volumes are growing and uh you know
while data is growing rapidly which can
grow up to
177 zero bytes by 2025 which was
predicted by gartner uh 80 or 90
of data uh around the world has still
not been learned from so we are only
able to learn maybe around 10 to 20 of
the data um so pat yourselves in the
back because here we are
data and ai enthusiasts uh we can
multiply forces to bring intelligence
from this data and i'm pretty sure we
can uh
we can have successful impact on the
ai and machine learning field
so let me walk through some of the
important considerations
uh that
we can do for machine learning
first is data reliability i'm pretty
sure you must have seen or come across a
lot of uh challenges
for your ml projects this is one of the
themes i have seen around data
reliability
this often refers to the degree to which
you can trust your data
when you train a model uh on reliable
data set it is more likely to give
useful predictions than a model trained
on unreliable data
um i'm pretty sure you might have
experienced that for example if you were
writing some data to a database table
but the power went out unexpectedly
right it's possible that only some of
your data would have been saved while
some of it
would not
uh now your database is in the
inconsistent state because you know your
power went out and now it's like a
partial data
uh and that is very difficult and time
consuming to recover from this is where
having the asset transactionality is
actually useful
they ensure that uh you know the highest
they ensure that you have the highest
possible uh reliable data
and it also ensures integrity and uh
your data never falls into an
inconsistent state because of an
operation that could uh partially
complete
second one is data conferencing
um so
data conferencing is needed when you
have multiple users working on the same
data i'm pretty sure
data is like a team support and multiple
people are trying to be data driven and
you know use your data to make
intelligence out of it so
you have to consider those scenarios
when you have multiple users working on
the same data set um so concurrency is
what becomes very important because uh
for long-running queries on data lakes
for example where queries and operations
may take a long time
this is where having a multi-version
concurrency control is important
it ensures that
when you have
multiple writers who are simultaneously
modifying that table
and uh it ensures that one when when the
scenario happens they are able to see a
consistent snapshot view of the table
and
there will be a serial order for this
rights
and for the readers what it means is
they can continue to see the consistent
snapshot view of the table that the
spark job uh started
even when uh you're modifying table um
in real time or during the job
then uh data quality so
it happens regularly that data teams are
working with a data set and find that
variables hold iranians data for
instance
a timestamp that
came from 1485 but you're only expecting
a time stamp from maybe like 2001 for
example but 1485 that seems pretty like
unexpected data right
in a similar fashion we might want to
avoid people accidentally adding columns
to the data uh that we are use using for
modeling right uh this is where having a
mechanism to allow
you to specify expected data quality and
also what should happen to data that
does not meet the requirement becomes
important
uh then comes data lineage so what if
you could see the exact version of the
data that you used for machine learning
and development and
what if you have ability to understand
your data dependencies
um the ability to track data lineage is
hugely beneficial for improving change
management
and reducing development errors but most
importantly it provides users the
visibility into the sources used for
analytics
which allows uh you know teams to have
increased trust and confidence in the
insights derived from that data you can
make much more
powerful impact and uh much more um you
know confident decision making if uh
that's available
uh then
data sharing so there is a growing
demand for ways to share data beyond the
walls of the organization with external
entities because i'm pretty sure
nowadays uh you work with a lot of
organizations and you want to be able to
have a good way to share the data
so
what happens is because you have the
constraints from this organization um
you know users are frustrated by
these constraints on how they can share
their data think csv files or file size
limits and once that data is shared
version control and data freshness are
tricky to maintain take a group of data
scientists for example
who are collaborating they are in the
flow they are in the rhythm and on the
verge of an insight but
they suddenly realize that they might
need uh another data set to come up with
the conclusion so they submit a ticket
to their id team or data team to access
the data and they wait
in
two or so weeks that takes them to get
access to that data that
time is lost conditions change in two
weeks and whatever the rhythm they were
in the momentum gets lost
so data sharing shouldn't be a barrier
to the innovation
um
iteration right uh so one mistake that i
see a lot um
is that when a feature gets into the
hands of the customers they don't think
about it as the beginning of the process
they think of it as the end and
i see teams make this mistake all the
time and they build some data-driven
feature they release it they find the
performance to be mediocre and then they
either roll it back or abandon the
project right
and you know sometimes these
organizations even
come away with the mistaken impression
that ml is
therefore not actually very effective
for the problem on the hand or
on their data
um when in fact they kind of quit at the
beginning right
so
you know start small and try to iterate
over rather than waiting for perfection
but do consider it as like a starting
job or iterative process
this is the right way to build is to
build and plan for iteration
uh you should assume that you are going
to start out with something that works
okay and you will need to measure
performance collect more data and
iterate till it's good enough right
uh and that's partly organizational like
um you know
having to invest time and iteration but
it's also how
you go about developing those models
you need to put in place any of the
instrumentation that will inform the
iteration process
and you also need to think about the
infrastructure that will support the
rapid experimental shift because when
you try to iterate uh think of it as
like you know failing fast and then just
picking that up and moving on with
another uh experimentation so that
infrastructure becomes also a critical
component
and then cost efficiency uh with the
growing data now you have to think about
the storage you have to think about the
compute and then maybe you have like a
lot of infrastructure problem uh
or maybe you know so many tools that
that it's hard to manage also
um you know back in my uh city bank days
uh we would do capacity planning two
years in advance one year in advance uh
and then
you know
sometimes what happens is whatever
problems you have at hand right now or
whatever decisions you are making right
now is based on like some assumptions
and maybe the trends you are seeing uh
in this uh
you know in this current time but what
happens in two years we don't know
so um
you know that's one of the problems so
what is happening is the adoption of
cloud has been like uh increasing and
organizations are embracing the cloud
culture
and this robust services that are made
available by our cloud providers like
amazon azure google cloud services has
made it easy and cost effective for
organizations to
quickly get started and they don't have
to like have a heavy investment uh right
at the get-go they can pay as they go uh
and what they consume so they don't have
to think about you know necessary sorry
debts uh in the future
moreover the tools like delta engine
apache spark um we are here at num focus
um
all of these tools are there to help
developers and ml experts to
leverage the best practices as well as
how they can hide
how they can perform the queries
efficiently so that the engine and
apache spark enables you to have
a high performance queries
and then uh to make um machine learning
projects more
productive the machine learning platform
needs to foster collaboration we all
agree that you know it's a team sport so
it should allow participants to use the
tools languages and infrastructure of
their choice
um so it should
you know it should provide a platform to
bring together all the teams data
engineers data scientists devops in one
place to share learn and collaborate um
you know data engineering and data
science is kind of diff
a little bit different from software
engineering space in that regards
because when you are building a software
it's all the software engineers who are
working towards it right but when you're
building an ai application you need to
think about data engineering you need to
think about how you're going to host
that data how you're going to process
that data you need id infrastructure you
need data scientists so all of these
people are there
as your task force to make ai
applications really uh successful
so basically you need to have a you know
secure
uh and collaborative environment to
foster that successful machine learning
project
all right um yeah so um maybe i'm
overloading with too much information
please do ping your questions in the
chat which we will take uh at the
end of this talk
so if you look at just the data platform
uh what it is and let's break it down
into three components uh first is uh
there is
data storage uh the raw data that goes
in there think about it as raw
ingredients
then data management and governance is
how
you organize all of the raw data um so
think about how do you structure how do
you put security around it how do you
clean it up and how do you make it
discoverable think about this as an
organized uh pantry that has
quality control it has labels and
basically it doesn't allow kids to go in
there and just grab
whatever they want
um
and finally it's data workload so how do
you take all these raw ingredients and
turn it into something
uh meaningful it's the engine that
converts data into insight so let's put
actual technologies into this context um
i'm a big fan of like uh analogy and
that's why i'm taking this food pantry
as an example uh so let's put uh actual
technologies into this context and you
will understand why data management is
so critical
so let's uh start with a data warehouse
uh back in 90s uh data warehousing was
one of the
very key critical components and um
you know back then uh
people were thinking about how they can
manage the data with the growing uh
with the growing uh need of
growing evolution of software um people
were just thinking how they can make
you know some intelligent decisions so
that's where the data warehousing got
started uh
and uh over a period of time uh this is
where data analysts and business users
get insight from structured data
from the storage perspective it is the
proprietary storage for structured data
only
so think about this like i can take
only
the food that's it i can hand the fruit
and it puts it behind some hidden drawer
and i will never have direct access to
it so
that's one thing
after that it really has good data
management capability right because as i
said um you know whenever that they did
etl processing back then uh all of the
missing data as well as uh you know any
correct data would get um eliminated
during the etl process and only the good
data gets through the pipeline so
some of it uh duplicate data or you know
noisy data gets removed but uh we will
see how important it is and how it
evolved uh but anyway for etl processing
during warehousing times um they had
very good data management capability
just for those reasons because uh they
could manage good data right um so
uh it spends ton of time making sure
that only the good food get in there
it's basically laid out you can find
exactly what you need with labels
expiration dates and uh
the one only the ones you can access
this is where data warehouses spent a
lot of time and they nailed this
capability right
uh and then uh it's only for sql and bi
workloads right uh for data warehousing
it only supports uh you know structured
and semi-structured data for example
and sometimes it's
it only has sql interface that's about
it so think of it like uh in a kitchen
you
they gave you an oven and you can only
make food bias
you can make the most fantastic food
price in the world
but if you want to make a pizza you want
to make a steak that is off limits so
that's how i like to think about it
from data standpoint ml is out of
picture in data warehouses
so the best example i can think of is
this is what it looks like and this is
like a warehouse where
you have this well organized world where
all the fruit is perfectly cut up for
you it is available but that's it that's
all you're gonna have available if you
want to put something else you really
can't because um you know it's
really uh inaccessible
from a data lake standpoint this is
where data scientists can explore data
and build models from any data but
what data teams want is they need both
bi and ml right and this is hard in the
old paradigm but now if you go to data
lake it said that i don't just want the
fruit i want an entire grocery store
it's a storage for all your data
anything that comes i want to be able to
hold it for you and it gets uh
organizations excited because you have
tons of data that needs to be added
value to so you just don't want a
portion of it but you want all of your
data to be hosted
now some of them are great but
what happens is
it has open storage for data which is
awesome
and then
it lacks data management and governance
because you must have hard data swamps
right because it's literally garbage in
and garbage out
uh there is no control around it and
then workload it does support ml and bi
but you know as i mentioned earlier
successful components of ml it lacks
some of the um some of the reliability
quality lineage aspects so those are
some of the challenges with data lake
and this is what you are trying to get
value out of literally like
if you're curious this is a picture of
grocery store after an earthquake
everything is on the ground half of it
is broken you don't know what is good
quality or any anything of that sort so
this led people thinking that this would
never work so now the key question is
uh what if there is a goldilocks way in
the middle of data lake and warehouses
what if i could borrow
that is a data management capability for
example reliability integrity security
quality from data warehouse
you can go get it but you should still
support all of the workloads right
because data warehouses just support bi
use cases but my use cases are not just
limited to bi now i want to do ai and
machine learning
what if i don't want to be locked in
proprietary store i want to own my own
it needs to be in in a format and have
the flexibility for the long term people
are thinking of things in a more future
oriented multiple year down the road
mindset right so there's so many
urgencies in the enterprise that it's
hard for people to take a step back and
say well three years from now what will
what will i have wished i did so
keeping all that in mind you need to
also have easy integrations with other
tools because you you will have
different um
different different skill sets in your
team so you want to be able to integrate
with your entire ecosystem
so what if there is a way to bring best
of both
both worlds from data warehouse and
data lakes this is this is not a dream
anymore
we have lake house now so this is what
lake house is the lake house is
effectively saying that i can bring all
of the data
uh
all of the data that and have the core
data management capability of foundation
and compute service to support all the
primary use cases
uh and
you know
you can have metadata caching layer
there is a
uh on top of data lake
and it can support business intelligence
and ai applications so when you hear us
talk about delta and how critical
um
you know delta is this is where
delta adds transactionality layer and i
will talk in a little bit but
all the
all the practitioners that i talk to
they are thinking about this lake house
paradigm um so
you know with the lake house much more
of your data can remain in your data
lake rather than having to be copied
into multiple systems uh which can be
costly as well as you need to think
about governance you no longer need to
separate data architectures to support
your workloads across analytics
data engineering uh streaming and data
science instead you are able to achieve
one common uh data foundation for all
your workloads
so this is what uh lake house is
so with lake house all the data teams
are happy
they can unlock brazilian use cases from
the data that they generate
and uh you know
it keeps all the data beams happy
so remember uh the slides from earlier
all of these were the considerations now
um you know this is what i have seen uh
lake house architecture at databricks uh
where uh you know
it has like a full data database machine
learning platform which is a data native
solution built on lake house
and
one of the key critical uh enable for
this lake house innovation is delta lake
uh data lake provides reliability
through asset transactions because it
has a transaction layer you can be sure
that all operations in the
data lake are either fully succeed or
fail with the ability to easily time
travel backward have the lineage for
your governance and
delta lake is underpinned by apartheid
spark and you utilize this advanced
caching and indexing method so you
remember when i talk about query
performance this is where it comes into
the picture and finally data lake also
provides fine-grained access controls
which gives you much more control who
can access and uh
what data in your data can be accessed
one more thing i mentioned about was
data sharing so now uh we have delta
sharing as well which enables
organizations to you know
just break the ceiling and share their
data extra with external teams in a much
more uh reliable as well as um you know
efficient fashion
so would you rather live here
or here
so
lake house is a mindset and
you know we have to welcome it into our
hearts
databricks we define the lake house we
take it religiously and even uh have the
music for it um which was repurposed
so
that's about my talk uh and you know i'm
also co-authoring this book if you are
interested to learn how you can
um leverage desolate to bring
reliability and um you know build
efficient ml pipelines please check it
out
also you will find me somewhere talking
about data breaks or delta lake uh and
i always give tech talks to the
community because i'm a huge champion
and advocate for community uh please
reach out in case if you have
fascinating projects that you want to
collaborate on or
just learn anything educational content
we are here
to support that
and these are my links
to on the social media please check them
out if you want to connect i'll be happy
to connect with you to answer any
questions as well as like do any kind of
uh collaboration
um with that uh
we will take questions but thank you for
uh being here and listening to my talk
thank you for being a speaker this year
um
let's see and uh
we're about to
and i invite anyone else who wants to
continue the conversation to her oh we
got one one quick one uh what is your
opinion on iceberg
when can using
data like be a poor choice in
enterprises
yeah uh good question um so uh
iceberg uh similar to uh uh delay there
are some uh
there are some uh you know some here and
there um
you know plus minuses for the lake
versus iceberg uh we are working on uh
you know some comparisons around it but
uh basically companies are
you know embracing all these
technologies um the tools of their
choice uh
so
i would say like you know iceberg is uh
is is in the similar uh realm um as
deadly uh
so i think
companies are uh kind of combining it
with other technologies to use it um i
haven't used it personally but uh so
that's that's my uh that's my comment
around that
uh and your question is when can uh
using delta lake be a poor choice in
enterprises
um yeah so sometimes if you have like a
smaller data set for example and if you
don't have a huge workload
you can uh you can maybe
get away with working on the edge
all right triple thank you to everyone
who came out
you have a wonderful day
awesome thank you all uh for joining and
thanks and to our amazing moderators
appreciate it